alors bonsoir je sais pas comment vous
vous appelez merci d'être là Thérèse ça
elle sait même pas ce qu'elle fait
là excusez-moi vous êtes alors parce que
juste vous étiez dans l'émission de tout
à l'heure qu'estce que qu'est-ce que
vous voulez
non mais qu'est-ce que vous
voulez soign vos
problèmeso faut que tu restes pour
soigner les problèmes C bah demand son
métierand son métier sors allez sors tu
me sa
s elle veut vous aider elleut vous
aider pour
problèmour pas besoin de ça comment ça
va th bien alors vous êtes qui vous
faites quoi dans la vie non mais c'est
non mais c'est vrai c'est
quiends métierattends métier le métier
s vous faites quoi dans la vie donc moi
je suis thérapeute de couple et
sexologue
voilà on a pas besoin de sexologue on
pas besoin tours besoin vous n' pas
besoin non si non mais alors on va faire
on va faire personne par personne poser
une question comment ça bah une question
de sexologie ou deou de thérapie voir
qu' a besoin de ça bon Daniel déjà c'est
mort frère sur la tête de ma mère ils
ont mis un écrito sur sa culotte ba CD B
CD tout doit
disparaître frérot sur la tête de ma je
te dis alors non mais chacun doit poser
une question c'est à nous de poser la
question merci th allez-y Jean-Michel
alors Thérèse non non vra qui non mais
alors on va voir non mais parce que tu
l'as pas la question tuas pas la
question attendez si vous êtes d'une
agitation on dirait
l'animateur franchement on dirait
l'animateuré chacun va poser une
question à thè merci d'être là mais on a
toute la nuit alors pour en
[Applaudissements]
parler là j'ai des audiences qui tombent
tous les quarts d'heur th oui alors toi
non question sérieuse si c'est pour êre
c'est pour être lourd tu sors tout de
suite c'est une vraie question non c'est
une vraie question j'ai lu dans une
étude que Tromp pouvait être mais non
c'est pas ça que dire l'histoire de ta
meuf sa meuf est enceinte il m'en a
parlé g à fout moi j'ai posé les
questions pour vous je vais tout
balancer et va te coucher avec ta tenue
là c'est quoi la question pour question
en fait ça meu enceinte ouais et il
voulait savoir est-ce que euh euh parce
que lui en fait
euh savoir s'il a dro mais dis-moi toi
qu'est-ce que tu veux celui-là il est
devenu fou sur ma vie la confiance ouais
mais quelle confiance frère c'est
Dary c'est un truc de fou Thérèse
qu'est-ce que vous voulez savoir je vous
explique ok tais-toi toi quoi tais-toi
tais-toi tais-toi sors ressors tu je
supporte
[Applaudissements]
plus supporte plus on va te sor en fait
sa meuf elle est enceinte à celu ou à
celui-là sa meuf elle attend elle attend
quelque chose
é qu'est-ce tu fais
là qu'est-ce que tu fais là je suis en
train de parler avec thér j'ai rien dit
justement sors je parle de
toi et il voulait ça il voulait savoir
si si en fait parce que comme ils font
moins le tu vois c'est normal est-ce que
c'est normal ouais c'est normal ça fait
penser
au c'est pas un de TR soleil hein je te
vois ils fut moins le bail parce qu'ils
font moins le bail est-ce que c'est
normal est-ce que c'est normal moins
quand il y a quand il une grand placeou
un polyinel dans le
[Musique]
tiroirore l'expression ou c'est quoi
alors non ça dépend pour chacun mais ça
peut justement au contraire mais la
femme ou l'HME Parme plus intéressant
pendant la grossesse pour P est-ce que
ça peut faire du mal au bébé oh c'est
vrai mais c'est pour ça non mais c'est
pour ça que j'ai peur moi c'est trop
mignon comme question question de
petit je vous ai pas dit mais
j'interviens beaucoup auprès de lycéen
je fais ça chaque semaine et donc ils
ont des questions du genre est-ce que
voilà comme ça donc encore j'ai vu 500
lycéens et ils m'ont poser ce genre de
question alors par rapport au à toutes
les questions qui tou à la sexualité
alors la question est trop trop mignon
évidment la Rép
je déjà vu tout nuul le bébé risque
rien allez sors sors sors sors sors
plusér tu SV de 1980 s sors sors sors
sors sors mais prends le siège prends le
siège va t'assoir
là-bas prends le
si prends le
si alors qui veut une
question non mais il y a Daniel elle ve
poser une question estce qu' il y a des
possibilités que ça se referme
complètement en cas de non utilisation
de plus de 20 ans non qu'est-ce vous
posz question par
par je viens d'avoir 60 ans ouais ou je
suis en jacher depuis une trentaine
d'ané véré je nai pas voilà je n'ai pas
vu le loup depuis une trentaine d'é 25
ans à peu près est-ce que voilà quel
conseil pour que ça se débloque pour que
parce qu'il y a quelque choseors
j'aurais peut-être une
idée c'est ça les cradeau je me bats non
non non non non on rigole ça va E th
c'est trop parler de sexualité fa pas et
toi parle avec celui-là parle avec cel
parle avec celui-là non mais est-ce que
c'est comme le vélo ça se perd pas quoi
parce que et en plus la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on peut avoir une vie hyper
belle une vie sexuelle incroyable après
60 ans témoign et surtout pour les
femmes parfois elles sont justement
elles n'ont plus peur d'avoir une
prochaine grossesse ou quoi elles sont
beaucoup plus ou
conissent puis après ans on se dit
toujours ça peut être la dernière fois
donc on donne tout c'est qu'on a une
autre intensité il y a plein de autres
façons de faire l'amour il y a ce qu'on
appelle le slow sex et cetera une façon
de faire l'amour sur le moncalier
Stana
génial dans la voiture à dans laignte
d'accord rir avec avec quelqu'un par
exemple de d'environ 10 ans pas
Jean-Michel c'est pour toi
e vas-y e parle pas de ça toi c'est bon
reste de façon appué comme ça tu tu
caneras pas tout de
suite Thérèse comme vous avez beaucoup
d'expérience et vous savez lire à
travers les les les regards et les
visages je voulais savoir si autour de
la table vous pouvez savoir et même
partout vous pouvez savoir qui a une
sexualité harmonieuse et développée et
épanouie ou au contraire qui est
complètement frustréou alors c'est hyper
intéressant comme comme question parce
que la réalité c'est que oui on peut le
voir quel quand une personne elle est
sexuelle c'est dire qu'elle sa dimension
sexuelle et qu'elle est à l'aise avec sa
sexualité ou qu'elle ne l' pas par
contre je ne ferais pas du tout
l fait trop peur moi j'aime pas sont les
signau qus sont les signaux de quelqu'un
quiit c'est une histoire d'énergie mais
vous l'avez déjà peut-être ressenti il y
a des gens qui ont une énergie très
vivante on sent qu'il a vraiment une vie
sexuelle qui est qui est joyuse VI
sexuelle ça veut pas dire d'avoir des
relations sexuelles tous les jours mais
qui a intégré sa dimension sexuelle et
il y a des gens qui ne sont pas sexuels
je sais pas si vousz remarqué qui a qu
d'teint c'est quelque chose qui qui se
dégage et en réalité il y a très peu de
gens qui sont très sexuels en plus de
gens qui sont un peu bloqués par rapport
à leur sexualité mais ça se ressent
complètement la vérité ver il est
bloqué c'est la vérité la vérité th il
est bloqué tu dis la vérité tu peux
alorsux tu peux l'écrire sur un papier
je dis
rien voilà s r tu par c'est vraiment mon
vrai métier donc tuas le dro de dire non
non je dir pas mon fr métier moi mais
mais ça se voit ça se voit que
non se voit que non mais rien n
irréversibleel qu'ellez tu vois pas
qu'elle vient de le dire vous le sentez
aussi ça veut dire on a compris pas dit
ça elle pas dit ça tu l'as dit mais vous
avez vre réponse j'ai ma réponse voilà
elle a dit elle vient de me dire que
tuétais
un mais parfois c'est vrai qu'il y a des
personnes qui peuvent paraître très
àaise avec la sexualité parce qu'ils
font plein de blagues et cetera ENIT il
pas
j'aime bien j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'aime bien j'aime bien c'est bien s qui
veut poser une question
à vraiment qu' est comme ça avec vous
moi j'aimerais bien vous poser une
question c'est pour un
[Rires]
ami pas moi c'est un po quand il a des
pannes sexuelles parce qu'il est trop
cérébral pas comment surmonter une
sexuel quand on est avec une partenaire
et que ça veut pas ça veut pas plus on y
pense moins ça veut pour moi c'est pour
un
pote ASCE ou pas asuce une astuce c'est
de se dire qu'en fait l'objectif c'est
pasement de performer l'objectif c'est
passer un super beau moment
ensembleobjectif avec elle de faire en
sorte qu'elle se sente bien qu'elle se
sent désiré qu'elle se sent qu'elle est
du plaisir et cetera mais dans dans
quelque chose qui soit très intentionnel
pour qu' soit bien tout se passera bien
si tu es concentré sur te performance à
toi pour pour te
rassurer marche
plus et bien s qu' des solution et c'est
V c'est dans le mentalou en fait
finalement on arrive très bien à faire
la sexualité quand le mental s'en le
moins possibleèon est dans tête plus
rien
[Rires]
fonctionne tules non non les deux je
peux plus euh je veux des questions de G
intéressants mais pas non vous vousvez
pas une question non ça va j'ai en fait
j'ai j'ai fait des formations pour faire
à peu près le même métier donc
jous
cons dégonfle de minutes non mais ça
m'intéresse parce que je fais des
consultations aussi j'ai le même
question bon attends attends une
question de Gill Verde alors attends
attends attends calme-toi parce que tu
vas pas la lancer comme ça ça vaut de
l'oseille
on va se retrouver dans un instant
question la question de Gill Verdet
madame hein qui va te répondre je sais à
peu près ce que tu vas poser comme
question ah pas du tout bah si je sais
ah ouais peut-on être amis avec l'amant
de sa
femme on va parler dans un tout de
suite